[SLIDE CLICKS]
NARRATOR: This is an image
of the surface of Mars, taken
by NASA's Viking One
spacecraft in 1976.
The picture is a triumph
of human innovation.
We built a piece
of technology that
traveled all the way to
Mars, took a picture,
and beamed it all the
way back to Earth.
But that's not why
this picture is famous.
It's famous because we all
see a face, right there,
staring back at us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's known as the
Face on Mars, and when
NASA released it to the world,
a lot of people freaked out.
There's still an entire
conspiracy theory section
of the internet devoted to it.
But all of that is
pretty easy to debunk.
This is not an ancient
monument to some Martian god,
nor is it the mask left over
from a giant race of aliens.
This face was created
because of the combination
of shadows and
missing image data,
known as bit errors-- which
comes with the territory when
beaming images back from
hundreds of thousands of miles
away.
These bit errors helped form
that deep and creepy the eye
socket.
You can see these black
holes all over the image.
But releasing the simple
explanation didn't stop people
from freaking out, so
NASA returned to Mars
to capture more
updated images, in part
to silence the skeptics.
Here's a photo from 1998, and
here's another one from 2001.
No face, no monument,
no proof of alien life.
Just a boring Mars hill,
something many NASA scientists
compare to the buttes
of the American West.
But there's still something
more going on here
than missing pixels
and dark shadows.
Something called
pareidolia, it's
the phenomenon of
finding meaning
in an image or sound, where
that meaning doesn't exist.
Like animals in the
clouds, profiles
in rocks, or satanic
messages in pop songs.
This happens in part
because people see and hear
what they want to see and hear.
And people really want
there to be aliens.
This has been
going on for years.
Nikola Tesla even claimed
to hear communications
from the red planet.
People today still
scour Mars rover photos
for any proof of alien life.
It's hard work, and it has given
us a lot of crazy conspiracies
to deal with.
There's the Mars iguana, an
ancient helmet, and the finger
bone of a deceased alien.
And I say it's hard work,
because when NASA delivers
high resolution
images like this,
someone has to
meticulously scour them,
zooming in until they
find their proof.
Be it an artifact, a space man,
or the ruins of a civilization,
or this guy.
Wait, that is definitely
a guy walking on Mars.
Mars has a Sasquatch.
This is all the conspiracy
theories rolled into one.
This Happened Here aims to
share compelling photos,
and the stories behind them.
If you liked this video,
be sure to watch this one
on what it's like to take a
selfie on the edge of space.
MAN: Really, in the space
suit, it was deathly quiet.
And I could look up to
the blackness of sky.
NARRATOR: Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]